85 year old woman punched in her
apartment dying a week later from those
injuries
and now the man accused of just randomly
hitting her tells the i-team
his life is over our david charns spoke
to that man
david has now been charged with murder
he is denise the heartbreaking part of
this whole thing is this was just
entirely
random the 27 year old tells me he was
on drugs and looking for a place to
sleep
he broke into this 85 year old woman's
apartment punching her now he agreed to
talk to us from jail but
did not want it to be recorded and we do
want to warn you that
some of the audio and some of the images
in this story may be disturbing
this is how 27 year old demetrius walker
who goes by the name
pharaoh describes april 21st he tells
the i-team i remember knocking on one
door
and no one answered and i remember
kicking it in investigators say he
knocked down the door of this henderson
apartment
85-year-old mary lascella was inside
walker tells the eye team
i heard someone scream i panicked turned
around
and ran 100
the 911 minutes after police say walker
punched the elderly woman
evidence photos show her mobility
devices and
alert necklace in her apartment the
victim badly beaten
but heroically able to speak with a
dispatcher providing
vital information so he was a black male
in his 20s
do you know what color shirt pants he
was wearing red
red shirt blue she tells that dispatcher
what walker was wearing
police later finding the shirt and jeans
burned in this bucket
but witness descriptions and video
surveillance confirmed that police were
looking for walker who has a cross
tattoo on his face
the 85 year old dying a week later in
the hospital
walker charged with her murder he tells
the i-team i pray for her
i'm sorry to the victim's family i pray
for them every day
he adds i accept everything i did i
acknowledge it
now if convicted walker faces a first
degree murder charge and the possibility
of life in prison because
of the victim's age the i-team did speak
with a family member who declined to be
interviewed
i'm david charns 8 news now brian